of las vegas as big as food and beverage
festivals great vegas is happening this
weekend brian chapin the ceo of motley
brews is here to tell us all about it
welcome buddy it's good to see you good
seeing you jc how you doing man 10 plus
years what can we expect this weekend
you know i mean it's been a little delay
for the 10 years but we finally came so
um you know two days of awesome las
vegas local
culinary mixologist and craft beer
providers and uh you know about 8 000
plus people out there to to celebrate it
on two days what is the tiki throwdown
yeah taco tinky throwdowns is is new uh
it's kind of a spinoff of the hop taco
throwdown that we did over at zappos for
about five years we've combined the
expertise of adam rains over at golden
tiki
on the mixology side with some really
awesome mixologists that he's put
together with 12 awesome culinary folks
put together by the feast of friends
folks um that are all basically culinary
folks that that have nothing to do with
the taco scene at all they're competing
to make the best tacos so we've done it
for like five years uh and so it's
always exciting seeing these chefs
compete to make the best taco in there
in their spirit yeah and then the drinks
to go with us that's happening on friday
night then saturday is the grand or the
great time it's great
on saturday that's kind of what we've
been doing for 10 years straight um the
great tasting is 400 different libations
mostly craft beer focused we have the
most local you expected to try all 400
other strengths i've seen people attempt
to try yeah yeah it's been a while i've
seen the attempt made and it's it
doesn't usually pan out but um but
there's you know there's a lot of local
craft breweries there which we love
that's kind of why we built this the
concept of great vegas featuring all the
great local folks um we've got over 30
local breweries out there almost
everybody from las vegas this year which
is incredible so
we're stoked to be welcoming everybody
back including the breweries the
mixologists and all the all the cool
culinary folks cooking out there it's
going to be great events great food get
great drinks real quick what do we have
here so what are some of the beers we
got here yeah this is a collaboration we
did with one of the local breweries big
dogs uh it's called doppelbach
with a ppe
kind of underlined in there to signify
that we made it during the pandemic you
know when ppp was a thing so if you look
at it on the front you know it's got a
dog kind of taking off his mask and
getting down with some doppelbach so
guys at big dogs and and everyone over
there have been great with us and so
it's it's a really tasty beer it's been
aged two years and it it can age and uh
it's it's tasting really good this is
pandemic age right here two years ago
the pandemics would start we're gonna
age our beer and boom now we're ready to
go that's right i love it appreciate it
thanks so much for joining us appreciate
it thanks now it's happening at downtown
las vegas event center this weekend the
great vegas festival april 22nd and 23rd
for ticket information go to
greatvegasbeer.com
now let's send it over to ted with a
look at our weather for the week and
weekend maybe